[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Ali, and this is Vic.
And today, we're going to
be talking about the
Google Drive API.
Specifically, we're going to
give you some tips and tricks
on which OAuth scopes
to be using.
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
So we have a series of different
OAuth scopes, and
they have very, very
different purposes.
They even apply differently
to different types of
applications.
In one scenario, you're going
to need a certain scope.
Whereas in another scenario,
you might
need multiple scopes.
So we're going to walk
through those today.
Right now, on our laptop here,
we're on developers.googl
e.com/drive/scopes.
I think you can see that on
the screen right now.
So if you take a look at this,
there are currently five
scopes that we provide to
Google Drive developers.
Ali, do you want to talk about
high level-- what the
different ones are?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, so can we
just mention that with the
Google Documents List API, which
was the API you used to
use to manage these
kind of files.
We only had one broad scope, and
these were in the infancy
of OAuth and OAuth 2.
So really we hadn't fleshed
out what we would like.
And this is one of the real
improvements we've made over
the Google Documents List API,
so one of the reasons really
to move across.
The scopes themselves are
firstly the full drive scope
is what we call Drive.
We've got the drive.file
scope.
We have the drive.readonly
scope and the
drive.readonly.metadata scope,
or metadata scope.
We have another scope-- those
are for reading data.
We have another scope
that is called the
drive.apps.readonly.
And that relates
to applications
that a user has installed.
We won't really be talking
much about that one.
We'll stick to the data
scopes for now.
VIC FRYZEL: So the reason that
we have multiple scopes, just
as a reminder, is to
benefit users.
This requires an application
to behave well.
But really a user has to
authorize less access to their
files to an application.
So, for instance, if
somebody requests--
if an application requests just
the drive.readonly scope,
an application is unable to
manipulate the files that it
has access to, but it can read
all the metadata and
download each one.
So this is very much less severe
than the full scope,
for instance.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's a perfect
place to start.
Shall we start with the most
restrictive scope there that
is probably the
drive.readonly.metadata scope?
VIC FRYZEL: Yep.
ALI AFSHAR: Now there are some
applications around that
analyze your drive to see how
much is used, and where it's
being used, and which kind
of files are using it.
These are really useful
applications for yourself and
even in a domain, if you have
a Google domain, you can
manage that across all of it.
So previously, with the
Documents List API, you'd have
to give that app access to do
everything on your drive.
Now, you can just say, well, I
only want this app to look at
the metadata for the
files and not be
able to change anything.
So very specifically, they don't
need to download files,
so you don't need to
give that access.
And users are going to be much
more willing to use your
application if they know you
can't modify the data.
VIC FRYZEL: And how does a user
know that an application
can't do that?
ALI AFSHAR: So when you first
authorize an application, you
get a list of what
the scope can do.
And this is quite
a common screen.
I'm sure you've seen it
before, the OAuth 2
confirmation dialog.
And it will say view files
or list files.
The more permissive scopes, they
will say other stuff like
can modify files, or
can upload files,
can download files.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly.
So with the metadata scope, the
readyonly.metadata scope,
you cannot download the contents
of a file, which is
super important to users who
are concerned about maybe
their confidential information
leaking to certain
applications.
ALI AFSHAR: So if you can't
write the content, what can
you download?
VIC FRYZEL: Just the
title, just the
description of the file.
You can find out when it was
last modified, when it was
last updated.
You can see a series of
its revisions and
who it's shared with.
But you can't actually
access the content.
So that's a big deal.
You can pretty much access
everything that you see in the
Google Drive user interface
until you click
to download a file.
So that's the readonly.metadata
scope.
We also have the readonly scope,
which is a little bit
more permissive.
Do you want to go into that?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
So the difference there
is that you can
also download files.
So you can see what
the title is.
You can see the size of the
file, but also the application
can download files.
Can you think of an example
when that might be used?
VIC FRYZEL: One example where
that might be used is if the
application Loop wanted to have
the ability to make a
collage of all of the photos in
your drive but didn't want
to save the collage back to
Drive, an application that
wants to perform some function
on the files there but not
actually write anything back.
So in this case, Loop would
have to collect the
drive.readonly scope.
They would have to go through
all of the images in your
drive, and they would
download each image.
And then given that,
they would be
able to make a collage.
This is where the example use
case ends though, because Loop
actually also must be able to
save the generated collage
back into your drive.
So this scope alone is not
good enough for that.
ALI AFSHAR: So if something like
an application that would
back up all your drive, or say
you select a few files, and
you'd like to make an archive
from those files, and just
download that zipped archive.
Something like that
would be perfectly
good with this scope.
VIC FRYZEL: There's a lot of
enterprise use cases for this,
for instance, like enterprise
audits or enterprise--
like let's suppose somebody
leaves a company or somebody
needs to back up all of their
stuff from Google Drive into
the company's filer.
Things like this are very good
for the readonly scope.
There's no reason those
applications need to write
anything to your drive.
ALI AFSHAR: Absolutely.
And we mentioned users being
happy to give you
access to the data.
It also applies to domain
administrators as well.
So a domain administrator is
much more likely to allow
users on their domain to use
your application if you use
quite a narrow scope
like this one.
VIC FRYZEL: Right.
Exactly.
To give also an example of
readonly.metadata, an example
of where somebody might use
this is if they were
implementing their own
picker, right?
You want to show the user a list
of all of the files in
their drive.
And for some reason, the
application has decided not to
use the picker that
we provide.
Maybe, for instance, a picker
on an embedded system like a
printer can't display
our HTML5 picker.
So instead, they generate their
own picker and allow a
user to select a file
from Drive.
In that case, you don't need
to download the files.
All you need really is like the
title and type of file so
that the user can see those
things and choose one.
And then once the user chooses
that, you also have the file's
ID, and then you can use that
to do other things.
So the two other scopes that
we're going to talk about
today are the Drive and
drive.file scope.
I actually think it might be
easier to talk about the Drive
scope first.
ALI AFSHAR: I think so.
So the Drive scope's
really easy.
It allows the application
access to do just about
anything the user can
do to their drive.
There's no restriction on that,
and that is equivalent
to the scope that you
would get for the
Documents List API.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: I mean, it's so
equivalent, in fact, that you
can use a token from the
Documents List API that you
got with Drive API.
And that's useful for people
who have migrated and they
don't want to reauthorize
the user.
VIC FRYZEL: So with that scope,
you can do anything
possible with the SDK.
Every single feature is
available to you.
Now, that's not to say that
you should use that scope.
You should use the
least amount of
access that you need.
And actually, that's where the
drive.file scope comes in.
That's the most important
scope, I think.
Because what this scope allows
your application to do is
access files like their metadata
and download them and
manipulate them that
the application has
either created or opened.
So if I have this scope and I
create some file, if I upload
a file to the drive,
I now have full
control over that file.
I can update it.
I can download it.
I can delete it if I need to.
ALI AFSHAR: And you
can list it.
VIC FRYZEL: And I can list it.
Right.
ALI AFSHAR: So it's a slightly
subtle difference.
The user authorizes your
application first.
But then you have to have some
kind of user input that the
user will explicitly say I will
allow this application to
use this file.
For example, clicking in the
Drive UI, or from the picker,
or from Android, these
kind of situations.
The user makes an
explicit choice.
So it's kind of like a filter
on the drive scope.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
So the drive.file scope is used
primarily by applications
who need to only manage their
own set of files.
They don't need to import any
data or manipulate in the rest
of the user's drive.
They just want to take
some set of files and
manage them in drive.
ALI AFSHAR: So we have some
examples, don't we?
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
What's an example?
ALI AFSHAR: So take Balsamiq.
I don't know if you
use Balsamiq.
It's a mock-up editor.
You create mock-ups for your
new website or your GUI
application, whatever it is.
They have their own
file format, BMML.
And those files are really are
no use to any application
other than Balsamiq.
One day, if they're huge, maybe
there'll be other people
who open that kind of file.
So that's really useful
for them.
When they get a list of the
files, they only get a list of
those files.
They can create those files.
They can read them.
They can do whatever they
like with them.
But it's kind of a subset
of the drive.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
So really here, Balsamiq
is a good citizen.
Like they're a good application
in that they're
requesting the least amount
of permissions that
they actually need.
They could use the full scope,
but they choose not to,
because it's better for users.
ALI AFSHAR: And something we
haven't mentioned much is that
you can combine these scopes.
So Balsamiq, if they wanted to
just list the titles and be
able to find which files are
actually Balsamiq files,
looking at all of them,
they could request the
readonly.metadata scope
with the file scope.
So they could be able to list
all the titles and only open
the ones and save the
ones that the
user explicitly allows.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: So mix and match.
I mean, they're specifically
designed to be atomic, so you
can take little bits of them and
join them together and use
whatever you like.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
So in the full scope, it's also
important to note that
another application with the
full scope could see
Balsamiq's files.
So if Balsamiq is creating all
of their BMML and accessing
those with the drive.file scope,
and another application
comes in and the user authorizes
it, that other
application could actually
impact those BMML files.
So it's important also when
you're working with these
scopes to realize that you're
not the only application
working with the user's files.
There's the Google Drive UI.
A user could come in
and move files, or
delete them, or do whatever.
And then a user could authorize
another application
to do the same thing.
So there's no way to have a
locked section or a locked
folder of files that are only
accessible by your application
at the moment.
So it's kind of something we're
considering, but at the
moment, we don't
have anything.
ALI AFSHAR: So this brings us
back full circle to the first
thing you said, Vic, is that
this is all for users.
And the user owns these data.
The user owns the files.
The user can say anyone can
open this file, whatever.
On a regular file system, you
wouldn't really lock it down
per application.
You would lock it down for the
user name or whatever system
you're using.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
Exactly.
So we are very fond of this
permission structure.
And in the future, as we add
more and more features to the
SDK, I suspect that we'll make
much heavier use of scopes so
that your application
can request just the
access that it needs.
So you should really look
forward to the future in which
we expose other scripts
to do other things.
ALI AFSHAR: Absolutely.
And as we said, very
fine-grained as well.
VIC FRYZEL: We've even received
a number feature
requests on adding more
fine-grained scopes, like
being able to add a scope for
instance by file type.
What if I only want to access
the images in a user's drive.
That's a very good idea.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, it's a
compelling use case.
VIC FRYZEL: So I think it's
something we're considering
implementing.
But that is a pretty good
summary, I think, of how to
use these scopes.
If you want to play around with
these scopes, you can go
to the OAuth 2.0 playground,
which is linked right here at
the bottom of this page.
And you can request the
different scopes and see what
the OAuth dialogue will look
like for the user when they
are granting access to your
application and see how severe
the messaging is and
things like that.
ALI AFSHAR: Obviously, we try
to make the messaging more
severe the broader the scope.
We don't want to scare users
away, but at the same time, we
do want to be absolutely
transparent and honest in what
the user is allowing
you to do.
So again, the less you use, the
less you ask for, the less
scarier it will look
for the user.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: And we are going
to a place where users are
starting to look through
this stuff.
I mean, a few years ago,
you could have said
people don't read that.
They just click OK.
But people do read that,
and people do care.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
We've definitely noticed a huge
increase in time spent on
that page reading through
these things.
Users pay attention.
All right, I guess that's about
it for Google Drive
OAuth scripts.
ALI AFSHAR: Great.
Thank you very much, everyone.
VIC FRYZEL: We will see
you all next week.
And thanks for watching.
ALI AFSHAR: Bye bye.
VIC FRYZEL: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]